joining us now with more Florida
Congressman Byron Donalds is with us sir
how are you
showing
we'll be with you
some clips of you later you're up
against what four or five liberals all
at once it's like uh you know four or
five on one but you got your points
across what is it about Donald Trump or
any conservative for that matter that
seems to trigger the mob in the media
uh it's because when you have
conservatives who are committed to the
facts and frankly who are not afraid to
Dish those facts out left and right you
mentioned last right last night it was
four five six ten the number doesn't
really matter when you're prepared with
the with the right information the truth
and you're not afraid to dish it out
they don't know how to respond to that
so the immediate thing is they typically
lash out look last night you know I'm
just trying to make a comment and
already three four and five of them are
trying to jump in but you got to stay
focused because at the end of the day
the truth of what is happening in this
country is what matters more than
anything that that silly reporters try
to talk about I mean look at our current
president this guy has three bank
failures and has lost three embassies on
his watch that's a disaster for America
and so it requires Republicans and
conservatives to be strong in this
position be armed with the facts and go
into any any situation and don't take
their bait come with the facts and push
back hard and this network is known for
lying for three long years being wrong
about so-called trump-russia collusion
that never happened we got it right on
this program uh thankfully we've been
Vindicated now many times starting with
the Horowitz report uh let me ask you
specifically about what town hall should
be about
um because I felt like Caitlyn Collins
was really doing a job for the for her
fellow quote journalists that are not
journalists they're talk show hosts like
me they're just not honest
um and not for the people because I
think if you ask somebody a candidate a
question whether you agree with the
answer or don't agree with the answer
why don't you let them finish the answer
and then do a follow-up question and say
Well then why didn't a b or c happen uh
why did she feel that she had to be the
special pleader for all things left left
wing
I mean well look personally I think it
was her or her own Super Bowl I mean
look Caitlyn's been doing this a long
time I've done interviews with her on
that Network and I think that this was
her time in the spotlight being opposite
the number one guy in our party being
Donald Trump so I think that's part of
it number two it was clear that CNN's
position was to do anything they could
to keep bringing up all of the old stuff
all of the narratives that they continue
to push and to ignore the realities of
what's happening in America today and so
I credit president Trump for frankly
keeping his composure with this
Onslaught from her and being focused on
the things that matter to the voters of
our country and not to the political
class and not to the pundantry that
frankly has gotten it wrong so much more
than it's gotten it right and by the way
have we not litigated January 6 to death
have we not litigated the 2020 election
to death uh are in elections about the
future we we now have an economy where
60 percent of our fellow Americans who
live in paycheck to paycheck do we not
see China on the March no consequences
for a spy balloon that flew all around
our country no consequences for Russia
uh taking out one of our drones uh no no
active uh response by Joe Biden when you
have an alliance of China Russia Iran
that should scare every American in my
view
no you're absolutely right but the Press
especially the liberal press they can't
focus on the president look at what we
brought out through the oversight
committee under the leadership of James
Comer we've documented that Joe Biden
and his family have taken money from the
Chinese and from Romania we've
documented that they don't want to talk
about that they don't want to talk about
the southern border all the things Sean
that you talk about the only thing that
will keep their agenda alive and at the
end of the day America it is about the
radical a left agenda for the Press it's
about that agenda and the only thing
that keeps that agenda alive is to talk
about the past and to talk about these
other things I think American voters
they understand what happened on January
6th it really was a really tough day for
our country but they're looking at
what's going on now and they're looking
towards the future and we need a
commander-in-chief who's focused on
getting America back on track all right
Congressman Byron Donald thank you we
appreciate you being with us hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else